the great Peter King of NBC sports and
and Peter uh I'm going to ask you a
question
if Kyle Emery sees what's going on in
baseball this kind of contract even
though he's completed his pro day last
week team say or speculation is that
he's rising up the draft boards you know
how can he just look at that contract
and say you know what I'm still all-in
with football well Kirk it's a great
great question but I guess the point I
would make is that Tyler Murray when he
went to Oklahoma Russ and he played
baseball he was a obviously a top
prospect in a very good prospect but to
compare even though he was the ninth
pick in the MLB Draft
last year but to compare his future
possibility in baseball to football
I think his probably is probably really
taking a giant leap of faith toward
baseball for this reason ok like he
played a lot in one year ok so like his
first year that he played it at Oklahoma
he only had 49 at-bats and he didn't
play a lot he only hit 120 - that was
2017 the reason I know this is I looked
it up and I was really really surprised
that ok so his his big Baseball year at
Oklahoma in the spring of 2018 a year
ago ok his big baseball season bad at
296 hmm they played everyday played all
the time but he bad at 296 he had all
this speed he stole 10 bases and he hit
10 home runs and I'm not saying that's
bad
at all I'm really not but he played 50
something games and and I'm just making
the point that Tyler Murray was taken by
the Oakland A's because they thought
that if he devoted all his time to
baseball
that he had a very good chance to be a
very good player but honestly there were
no guarantees whatsoever about Cuyler
Murray in baseball you watch him in
football and other than the fact he's
five-ten and and eight other than that
it's kind of hard to believe that that
anybody could have any real doubts about
whether he'll make it or not I don't
have many and again who knows anything
could happen but I think he looks at
this and he likes football more so I
don't I don't know why the Mike Trout
contract today would have him sitting
putting his thinking cap on and say I've
made a terrible mistake by taking
football I don't I don't think in any
way no I don't think so was well I think
he's positioned himself quite well Peter
but just when you see those dollar
figures you're like oh my god but it
still goes to show that the NFL is a
quarterback driven league and Calipari
will be drafted at some point in the
draft whether it's number one overall or
top five first-round I think for sure
but I think about another guy who was
drafted pretty high a couple of years
ago by the Jacksonville Jaguars and
Blake bortles now people thought he
would be you know a guy who would kind
of each year get better and better
started in an AFC Championship game and
now reports that he will be the backup
to Jared Goff and I know you've spent a
ton of time with Sean McVeigh especially
on the ride to work with him before
what makes this signing for Blake
bortles to the Los Angeles Rams what
makes us a good signing for them you
know his first year with the Rams 2017 I
remember going to training camp I and
watching Sean McVeigh work with the
quarterbacks and at the time I thought
that there was a chance that Jared Goff
really might not be that good but I saw
the time that he was investing every
practice every day with the quarterbacks
Dan Orlovsky was in camp he ended up not
making it Sean Mannion was there
the Oregon State quarterback and and
golf and I'm sure there wanted to other
guys but but Sean McVeigh was coaching
those guys like every day and you know
like throughout most of practice and it
was just Shaun McVeigh is going to isn't
this is a perfect place and I would say
this if it were almost any quarterback
but especially for Blake bortles who has
been damaged badly who has had one
really positive significant kind of
extended blip on his radar and that was
sort of maybe in the last two months of
the 2017 season and you know where you
know if Stephon Gilmore doesn't make the
great acrobatic play in breaking up that
pass in the last couple of minutes of
that game bortles could have led them to
the winning touchdown and and a Super
Bowl berth and he never would have been
cut they probably would have signed a
long term but you know to a contract
that really meant something but I think
that he's going to get the most
individual attention hey it's like going
to going to play football for Andy Reid
it's why or Sean Payton you know you go
to one of those guys or Kyle Shannon you
go to one of those guys and you fail it
is on you we're talking to NBC Sports
Peter King joining the Rich Eisen show
Kirk Morrison filling in for rich and
and Peter I remember seeing Ryan
Fitzpatrick I think a couple years ago I
was down at Tampa Bay Buccaneers
training camp and he's one of my old
teammates my quarterback when I was at
the Buffalo Bills and I said Ryan you
know we're the same draft class why are
you still playing like what he's like
Kirk I keep trying to retire but they
keep dragging me out of retirement is I
can't turn down this kind of money and I
say that because the Miami Dolphins sigh
and Ryan Fitzpatrick and I'm thinking is
this for real or is this a situation
where they need a placeholder for right
now to kind of get this team turned over
and the looking almost not toward the
2019 season
could be ahead in 2020 basically Peter
that's my way of them saying that there
this is a easier way to say that we're
not taking but we're actually tanking
like what's the deal with the signing of
Fitzpatrick to Miami I mean you know
it's almost like he was the last
competent quarterback left standing and
what choice did the Miami Dolphins
really have but you know I wrote this
Monday and my column Kirk that you know
if I I and you know you got to be
careful with this because I am I
desperately I'm against tanking right I
think it's stupid I think it's an insult
to the people who pay money to go to
your games you know III live in New York
I don't know how much a ticket to see
the Knicks cost but I assume it's a
monstrous amount of money and basically
the Knicks are putting a product out on
the floor that you know if you gave
James Dolan sodium pentathol he would
say I hope we lose you know and I want
to get the first pick in the draft
because I want Zion Williamson it's a
heinous ridiculous way to operate
however however however you know the one
thing that the Miami Dolphins have to be
concerned with more than everything else
is getting their long-term quarterback
in the future let's say they don't think
that let's say they don't think they can
get Kyler Murray and I don't think they
can and let's say that either they don't
love Dewayne Haskins or they don't think
they can get them and they're not in
love with any of these other guys they
you know whoever you know Daniel Jones
whatever it is so so let's say all those
things are the case you know then the
Miami Dolphins need to make sure that
whether it's in free agency unlikely or
the draft in 2020 they're in the best
possible position to get the best
quarterback they can and that to me has
to be their first second and third goal
of the 2019 season because in the NFL
you're never going to win unless you
have a highly competitive quarterback so
that's what I wonder about right now
with Miami you know did Miami go a
little bit saw
Don teddy bridgewater because a they
weren't really sure about him because I
don't know how you can be a late in a
while and and even when he played I
didn't know if he was a franchise
quarterback you know so did they did
they go a little salt on Bridgewater
because they weren't convinced on or
because they don't why would they want
to go 7 & 9 I mean that just puts them
further away from getting their
quarterback next year so at some point
you got to bite the bullet and say we're
gonna do everything we can to get our
quarterback in the next two years
I believe that's Miami's biggest goal
right now he's the host of the Peter
King podcast he's Peter king of NBC
Sports
during the Rich Eisen show Kirk Morrison
filling in for rich Peter hear me out
here because I kind of came to this
epiphany yesterday I was thinking about
you know over the last couple of days
being here in Los Angeles and you know
what's going on with LeBron James and
all of his extra things he's got off the
court and so you know he has this show
called the shop that's on HBO and you've
seen some you know NFL players on there
and for some reason I was thinking about
it yesterday right Peter and I think
it's been three NFL players who have
been on the show and the three NFL
players who actually went on the show
were on different teams after they got
off the show which were Antonio Brown
who we know has been traded from
Pittsburgh to Oakland Odell Beckham who
was on Episode one he's been traded from
New York now he goes over to Cleveland
and Michael Bennett who was a
Philadelphia Eagle is no longer an eagle
he's now with the New England Patriots
so is there something now where players
are NFL players are seeing that they've
got a little bit more power than they
probably didn't know that they had in
years past because we've seen a lot more
movement I feel like this free agency in
terms of trades and guys kind of getting
you know different deals other places
look Michael Bennett didn't do anything
of a you know of a disruptive nature to
get traded out of Philadelphia I think
that the Eagles wanted to use his money
on other people right but both the
Antonio Brown and and Odell Beck
Jr were disruptive factors at times
certainly on their teams and in fact I
believe he Antonio Brown did that to get
out
Odell Beckham jr. I don't know whether
she did or not but he certainly was
disruptive at times jus Rosenhaus was on
my podcast last week and he talked about
this exact thing he said I would hope
that if there's one thing that was
accomplished with the Antonio Brown
story over a long period of time two or
three months that it is that if you're
in a situation you don't like and you're
willing to take some risky and potential
image damaging consequences you can get
out of where you want to where you are
now not every team is going to
accommodate you I am convinced curt yes
that if Cleveland Browns did not put
your grilled peppers in that trade
package for Odell Beckham that Beckham
would never would not have been traded
and I was told that absolutely so so I
mean we're all saying that well Odell
got what he wanted he got out of New
York for whatever reason I don't know
why somebody who you know loves the
fashion scene goes to Paris and sits on
runways and whatever it's bizarre to me
that he would be making noise and
seemingly being a disruptive factor with
the Giants but be that as it may
he's out of New York now and and I think
part of the reason is that he was a
squeaky wheel it's the same thing as a
Antonio Brown but Kirk I think if
players are going to do that and if they
want to do that they have to be willing
to be very strong and to take an
incredible amount of public acrimony fan
hatred all that kind of stuff for that
to work if they're not willing to be
unpopular then they're gonna have to
suck it up and stay on the teams or they
owe you mentioned the you said the word
unpopular which kind of leads me to my
next question Peter an unpopular
player was kind of sacrificed yesterday
and that unpopular player would be
vantes Burfict he was released by the
Cincinnati Bengals Zach Taylor new head
coach comes in and talks and says hey
it's kind of a mutual agreement almost
that it's better for him to get a fresh
start and us as the Cincinnati Bengals
get a fresh start there will be a market
I feel for vantes Burfict obviously one
of the leading candidates says oh he
looks like a Raider plays on the Raider
what would that dynamic look like would
vantes Burfict Antonio Brown and we know
the history between those two between
the Bengals and Steelers but if the
Raiders were to save on tez Murphy can
we just sign a petition that we want the
Raiders as hard knocks for this season
please laugh let's just go ahead and
start the petition now Peter because
that is must-see TV in a summer in which
we love access how great would that be
the Raiders all their deals it will not
taste worth what I think would be really
interesting about that and that's the
first thing I thought of is and I don't
know the answer to this question I
should but I don't
Jon Gruden has great regard for his
defensive coordinator Paul Gunther Paul
Gunther obviously had been in Cincinnati
right and it coach Vaughn says perfect
for several years I do not know if
Gunther is is telling Groot and hey
listen let's take this guy give them a
proven contract and if it works out
it'll be a really good player for us and
if not we just let them go that's the
thing Kirk you know this right because
you had to deal with it you know in the
NFL if you don't give a guy a lot of
guaranteed money you know and you sign
him in in April let's say okay you don't
have to pay him anything other than
expenses right until Labor Day you know
it's it's a it's a free look imagine
this imagine having vantes Burfict
around your team for five months for
free basically and again for free I mean
you know I'm talking about what you have
to
pay a guy in train gave all that other
CDL we got it yeah the little premium
that we got yeah yeah but but players
don't start getting paid their regular
salaries until week one of the NFL
season so in other words if you sign
Montez birthday let's say that you know
the Raiders did this okay if you sign
him today you you do not have to pay him
a salary for almost six months and
that's why I think that if paul gunter
went in and told Gruden hey let's give
it a shot what do we have to lose there
is nothing to lose and so let's say
you've got to give him some little
guarantee and I say little butt so you
get him a hundred thousand to sign he's
not gonna make a lot of money I wouldn't
think in any guarantees because
everybody's afraid of it right and
rightfully so but I I think he'd be an
interesting gamble for some team to take
because when he plays he is a top third
impact linebacker in the league but
there's so much other crap around him
that I wouldn't I wouldn't guarantee him
anything I would have him on the team
and I would basically say look as long
as everything works out as long as
you're here working hard and you know
you play well and you don't have all
this crap that has a company to you in
the past you're going to be a really
good part of our team per week roster
bonuses blah blah blah but once that
other stuff starts you got to get rid of
them that's the way I do with them so
that's a YES on hard knocks right Peter
I'd love to be hey listen I would love
the Raiders on Hard Knocks whether
vantes Burfict was there or not I think
it would be it'd be fantastic all good
all is well with I appreciate the time
Peter always thank you no problem Kirk
enjoyed it take care thank you that was
a peter king of NBC Sports the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience